hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley a couple of good-looking boys
right there i'll tell you that
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is ru garbage the show where we sit
down with your favorite comedians
and find out if they grow up classy or
if they're a complete piece of trash
i'm your host h foley stumbling over his
words here on a beautiful day here at
gas digital studios
in the big studio in the east village or
what is left of it
it's like a demilitarized zone out there
bombed out and depleted right from the
studio to the uber ladies and gentlemen
that's my [ __ ] tip
for the summer in new york city my
co-host coming at you
right next to me he's a good kid he's
got a brand new uniqlo shirt on we
stopped
he ran in i kept the car running he
looks fresh
gang he is the brains behind the
operation and as i always say
the next time you're reaching for a best
pal you go ahead and make it a kippy
give me a nice big round of applause for
kevin james ryan hey
hey all right one person appreciate it
new york stop it huh not to brag but i'm
back in an xl this is the first xl
in a couple of years kippy put on a
little bit of pound couple digiornos
a few more pounds few less hair
follicles you know what i mean that's
the gippy you know and love
happy to be here guys thank you so much
for listening uh we're back in the top
200 baby yes sir
loving it thank you for everybody that
uh you know that left a review on itunes
and subscribed as well
uh full video available on youtube you
can subscribe there as well
also you can get full hd access to the
complete
library of all gas digital shows if you
go to gas digitalnetwork.com use promo
code
a y g get the shows early you get the
chats you get the live streams
plus we get to wet our beaks a little
bit you know what i mean a little bit of
keys a little bit of cash in kippy's
pocket that's what we like
and we are tanking waiting on steve
mnuchin to drop another [ __ ] check
out i mean
i needed that 1200 like [ __ ] three
months ago let's go
and gang we could not be more excited to
have our very special guest here with us
today
she is an accomplished stand-up comedian
writer podcaster and actor
you've seen her on tlc comedy central
true tv and just about everybody's
podcast
but the big question in everybody's mind
today is is she
garbage i don't know ladies and
gentlemen you know her you love her
karen see han everybody hi yeah thanks
so fun
thanks for doing the show no problem i'm
thrilled to be here i'm so excited
thrilled to have you now let me ask you
this off the jump
yes you're well known everybody knows
you everybody loves you
do you think you're garbage well i it's
such a nuanced
it is then we'll get into it can i be
that i think that that's about
perspective
yes okay because i think that wealthy
people
would see me as garbage sure sure me too
we're all in the same boat on that one
that perspective we're trash
i can't buy a crab cake and i don't mean
rich people i mean wealthy people like
old money like classy like people who
sort of float around
in these souls these souls they're
shitty too
they can be true but these souls of
wealth that sort of like
they don't even it doesn't even matter
what they look like they don't even care
they don't even care to like improve it
sure they just sort of like
wear sunblock count their money and like
live and build hedges up so people can't
see how many kids they're [ __ ]
you know very protective very private
like to those people i think they would
see me as
trash to the average comedian i'm
[ __ ] rich
yeah there you go all right there you go
i forgot about that you have to realize
we're coming from within comedians
right comedians that's a low [ __ ] bar
yeah that is a low ball
not every comedian obviously so i'm sure
people are killing it sure
but i mean my circle rich people
definitely can be trashy because i was
in the hamptons not too long ago
the town next to the hamptons yeah a
little bit further down the long island
expressway
but we stopped at this nice roadside
stand and this [ __ ] it was like a
rolls-royce this old lady pulled up in
the rolls-royce
she got out she went over she was
arguing with the
with the with the lady that ran the
fruit stand and then gets back in the
car and then i see the lady with the
fruit stair runs back over it turns out
she was returning cherry tomatoes stop
it returning cherry tomatoes
and here's the best the [ __ ] lady
catches her she's like hey
you're returning these i was nice enough
to return them but you [ __ ] ate half
of them you're kidding
she was [ __ ] eating them out of a bag
in the [ __ ] car
she [ __ ] spun out oh my god it was so
great to see her called out she was like
that [ __ ] that doesn't bother her though
you know what i mean she's moving on to
go return blueberry somewhere she don't
give a [ __ ]
she found under her seat yeah so that's
what we've kind of that's exactly what
the podcast is all about is that you
could be from anywhere you could be
garbage you could not be garbage it's uh
you know it's a it is a very
minutiae kind of thing which is great
thrilling yeah i'm really excited to
talk more about it
we're happy to have you here where are
you where are you from originally i'm
from massachusetts
oh i grew up in a town called marshfield
which we used to call mash vegas
that's pretty good that's real tragedy
that's awesome it was like a trashy and
wealthy town it was both
those are my favorite towns i grew up i
was very similar
uh very similar town and like the
dichotomy because you are around like
rich people yeah
who are like but you're also friends
with charlene who taught you how to get
fingered
yeah yeah she was like cousins with one
of the new kids
yeah we just go to our house and wait
for joey to show up i swear to god and
like
i'm sure she made it up why did you call
it vegas though was there gambling or
something was it a resort town or
anything she just said no it's just
trash
so it wasn't like some shitty local
casino because they've done that in
philly a lot that's funny
oh the sugar happens real shitty oh god
yuck shout out to the sugar house
you owe me a bag of meth i'll tell you
that that's a beat bag
they don't open until 3am at that place
all right and you grew up brothers and
sisters what was the story
yeah i have an older brother younger
sister i most of my the people in my
family are teachers
everybody is a teacher that's very
respectable okay i agreed very noble
profession and then my dad's in sales
what's he sell so am i no um
he he was just work for a college uh
textbook company so he would
like drive up and down new england he'd
like drive to and from maine in like a
day
traveling salesman because he loved it
he got he's like willie lohman he loved
us so much he would come home and we
would listen to him pee
because he wouldn't stop on the way home
he would hold his pee all the way home
and then we would all listen to how long
he peed for
that's that normal decent piece what's
the situation strong stream
wow all right strong stream doesn't
equivocate large now i got a
there's a horse in there i got nothing
but it sounds good on the audio you know
what i mean
you switch over to videos there's an
audi this is an audio platform people
want their money back all right so you
grew up there brothers and sisters
um middle class upper middle class i
would say upper middle
just because of my dad's extremely hard
work ethic
like we're talking like 60 70 80 hours
and then to make you probably made like
over 100 grand a year that's good back
in the
80s and 90s that's clean [ __ ] living
making money you know and
meanwhile my mom was getting her
master's while working as a teacher so
she
eventually started making close to that
and then he got laid off the day i got
accepted to college
where'd you go to college i went to
marymount manhattan college got kicked
out of two dorms thank you so much
good for you yeah all right that's the
real school though my cousin just got
rejected
that's a real trash to i'll just grow it
like in college there was always the kid
or the girl who got thrown out of the
dorm in the first like three weeks i
mean how the [ __ ] did you manage to get
thrown out in three weeks it's so funny
you look back on that and you were like
like you know
we were in those situations too like oh
we got caught smoking weed like what's
gonna happen
nothing ever [ __ ] happened you get a
[ __ ] other doorman that was it
you and unless your dorms are in a
luxury building on 55th street then you
get three chances community service and
then they boot you out and then you
gotta start being a waitress and pay
your own right when you're 19. which was
fun anyway is that what happened
yeah what what kind of what place you
start working at community service
what the [ __ ] like for the college not
for like the state or oh that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the cafeteria in a jumpsuit
yeah
you know a chain gang like karen is that
you going to the party you go to the
five sigma party handcuffed to some
drunk sorority girl yep
stop crying tammy yeah but no so that i
was like oh i'll just get a job
while i go to college where did you
start working i worked at moe's
caribbean which is a bar on the upper
east side
do you know it it's trash is it i don't
think it's called brother jimmy's
it's very similar we i was like the girl
that would like pour like booze down
your throat
that is so trashy yeah yeah yeah and
then like give you a lobster with the
other hand
like it was like food booze i would
black out every
shift yeah you were a big booze big
booster oh yeah i would black out and my
it was like a sports bar too so anytime
and i'm from massachusetts and i'd know
nothing i would i would know one
player's name and i would just be like
screaming wasted like ghost socks
inevitably i would wake up the next
morning in a yankees jersey at some
dude's house
everybody's like [ __ ] you fear gary
cheater giving you cab money yeah hey
who won that game
and a goody bag you're signing you're
signing an nda on the way out the door
i'll tell you what that's classy as [ __ ]
man shout out to derek cheater i love
you but he knew how to do it he did
he was pretty good um do you still booze
or not oh i'm well this time
i haven't had a drink in over two years
hey congrats yes thank you
and you've kind of shaken the
massachusetts accent as well yeah i mean
but all i got to do is go home to my
mom's
and it's just trash right back right
back garbage
garbage what do you think is trashier
the boston accent or the philly accent
philly 100
disgusting it chills through my spine
i have it so i have it bad you don't
really need her
i say water and chocolate yeah well he's
going over there yeah over there
when i when i when i go home it [ __ ]
it hits me
especially after a couple of coors
lights yeah good night
i dated a guy from philly foreign i
dated a guy from philly forever for like
eight years i dated him
eagles fan psychopath yeah yeah that's a
different level of trash
but like i think there's there's a
romance behind
the boston act like the message there's
romance like in the movies like
it's the cool accent yeah and when you
meet some guy
it's like having a british accent when
ben affleck is saying it with a five
o'clock shadow and a [ __ ] ak-47 in
his hand
it's real [ __ ] sexy yeah he's like
you're gonna embarrass my friend
in this bar you're not remarkable ah i
love it i don't know
philly philly's pretty trashy i would
say philly's trashier than boston
i think the midwest though which is
where i get a little bit of my accent
from because i was born in upstate
pennsylvania
and they tend to carry like a buffalo
midwestern accent yeah i think the
midwest
is the trashiest especially gender-based
between females and males see i think a
sturdy south accent is the grossest just
like the
trashiest okay that is kind of tough you
get like you get like a chick from
florida or something that's like
awful i've been fingering myself i don't
know what's
up what's that such a shame you can't
sound you can't not smart you can tell
me to spell
encyclopedia it sounds like you just
bought lottery tickets
like that's exactly what it sounds like
i would like to address this class of
2020 i
am the alma mater yeah yeah i am
pregnant they clunk off words
moderately no you're not you force gump
sounding goofball
[Laughter]
all right let's get into some ru garbage
we're gonna play a little game here
karen called are you garbage game
kevin and i are gonna ask you a series
of questions we would like you to answer
the questions
as honestly as possible and obviously
they trigger any stories or memories
the worst the memory is please share
with the audience
yeah okay um start out simple what was
the name of the street that you grew up
on peterson path
peterson that's [ __ ] that's class wow
i don't think i've ever heard a path it
was a nice story i picture like dunes
and like
peterson path is a nice neighborhood it
was really nice there was a few italian
families one pair of lesbians
irish catholics it was a nice mix there
you go that's pretty good that's the
best one we got
peterson path all right what was the
name of the grocery store you
family went to growing up oh um god
i don't know my mom always went what was
it called it'd be weird if you were
going that'd be trashy
yeah she's sending you at 11. go get me
a pack of smokes you dumb whoa
no shoes i i don't know super something
super fresh
super supermarkets supermarkets
next to each other too really not smart
okay and so you grew up in a
single-family home i presume your dad
was bringing home some cash
like you know suburban single-family
home yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah had your own
room yes
not only did i have my own room i had
the master bedroom when my parents moved
downstairs when we started hearing them
[ __ ] when we got a little older like 11
12.
so my brother who was three years older
than me got the smaller bedroom and my
sister got a smaller bedroom
i got their master and my dad put a
ballet bar in my room so i could
practice and i had full length mirrors
that's pretty classy how what know what
that the parents that the whole family
decides that they're all gonna just
listen to the parents [ __ ] and they
move the children around that's garbage
no that's like porn star weird garbage
what's garbage is that your parents move
downstairs anytime the parent's bedroom
is on the ground floor
that is trashy right yeah or the
kitchen's upstairs what the
[ __ ] no they were on the same floor as
the kitchen they were downstairs did
they remodel to build that room or was
that just an extra room in the house no
they did they they
they it was a nice room that was a big
like it was always there they put it on
i was always there they're trash and was
it a bedroom it was a bedroom on the
first floor they turned it into a
bedroom
what was it before yeah i mean there was
we still had a bedroom a living room a
dining room
a kitchen and a bathroom on that floor
and then we had a finished basement with
a good clean living like a nice tv
and then three bedrooms another bathroom
upstairs i also like do you think your
parents put them the mirrors were there
for them to [ __ ] hardcore but they
weren't there for the ballet training
they were there
they were there for the peaky peeky you
know what i mean i gotta get rid of the
swing
that was weird the parents put some
mirrors on the ceiling too
thinking of my parents [ __ ] brings me
nothing but joy at this point in my life
that's pretty good i've never heard my
parents have sex once
yeah i wouldn't want to i don't know
i've seen them they're [ __ ] they
produced you it's hideous i vader's
still doing it though shout out to patty
i love you baby she's doing it with
somebody i don't know it might not be
your dad
oh [ __ ] you listen shut up he's sitting
on his chair right now
[ __ ] pissed off at you i'll tell you
that um
all right did you have a garage uh no
no garage no no okay no swimming pool
nope
big backyard yep who cracked the grass
my dad
he did yeah he was a riding mower or
push mower um
push in the beginning we could ride on
later on in life
but push for a long time that was like
it was good it's like the only exercise
he got but he was obsessed with his
laundry
green on the block wow really yeah
that's cliff while the guy who takes
pride in his lawn i'm obsessed like
mulch day was like
mulch day don't talk to me it's like a
mulch day
that's pretty good fresh mulch every
spring that's a [ __ ] sign of a classy
gentleman right he was good yeah
but unfortunately your father is not on
trial here sorry
you are right okay what with the
christmas decoration situation
uh we did colored lights
[Laughter]
ouch we did colored lights we made fun
of people who just did white lights
because we thought they were boring
that's classy that's classy it's
understated it's sophisticated [ __ ]
the griswolds did colored lights yeah
real tree
uh yes always okay that's pretty good
one tree or multiple trees
just one tree okay do you guys do tinsel
on the tree yes
love tinsel it's the most fun part is it
chinese throwing it everywhere
yeah no the dog eats it it hangs out of
his [ __ ] it's a whole thing
it's a whole thing with the tinsel i
love tinsel oh
i can't get a read on her right now at
least the upbringing
yeah um i wish you could know the name
of the supermarket that would be a big
thing i'm telling you it was star market
it was one of them and the other one was
what did i say
supermax supermarket it can't be
supermarket supermax i'll text my mom
there's no way there's a company out
there called
[ __ ] supermarket supermax let me text
my mom you guys
hi i'm [ __ ] here i'm jim donnelly i'm
the ceo of supermarket supermarkets
come on down we got fresh party today
it's got some [ __ ] halibut came in
[ __ ] tuna kid
yeah that's tough nothing in the
backyard though um so we had a shed that
looked just like our house
yeah so we had like a house replica shed
is that cute or whatever that's [ __ ]
dude my neighbors got that they bought
like the farm house class
like on the block and they redid the
outdoor shed just like the [ __ ]
farmhouse
well as a kid i was like you [ __ ]
sucking [ __ ] i wanted that i
have a great story about the shed
what do you got so it would so everybody
came to our house first chris um
it's winter time because it was the best
sledding with the most hills two huge
hills
that like converged in the yard in the
yard in the backyard what huge
so you had some oh okay a little bit
acreage huge backyard and then
the shed was down in the like bottom so
all these like there's like a little
hill here and then a hill that came over
here a hill that came up a little higher
and then
they all converged to this pit
essentially right so we got
the um the shed that looked like our
house later on
and it snowed and all the snow melted
and it was like a straight up like a
little pond
and it flooded the shed okay so my mom
goes in there with a suck pump
yeah yeah the like the wet vac yes but
she's
in knee-high water oh and she plugs in
the suck bunk
or the
they sound like sexual performances yeah
she gives them the suck [ __ ] you know
when you go in the shadows
paused on it yeah she's like looking at
me i'm like is this an innuendo
what is mr mrs these guys are [ __ ]
they can turn shocking each other
i love you guys how about catching a
movie or something
read a book that's where people so she
electrocutes herself
she electrocutes her whole body like no
no reason she should be alive right like
you're in like yeah
i think that's like dunzo you're in
charge of children to be honest with you
she walks in downstairs in the laundry
room and we're all standing there cuz
we've just been sleeping she looks like
marv from home alone yes
no she can't move she has like no
expression she's like mommy just
electrocuted herself
jesus yeah but then because
and then another year my dad um built
like some wood around it and let it
when it froze so it got really cold and
we skated on it a little bit
oh that's pretty good yeah it's pretty
that's i don't dude
this is [ __ ] this is up and down i
don't know what's going on
she's so like a nice like kind of
picturesque childhood minus the weird
room [ __ ] but
that's yeah that's i was
that's like out of like movies you know
what i mean that's where like the
the main character lives and moves into
the parents bedroom or something what
about the
what was the jungle gym situation back
there was there a swing set yeah
a tree fort swing set and then one year
my dad built us a tree fort and then
hurricane bob flew it away when
hurricane bob came and flew away
that's a real trashy hurricane name i
don't know i don't remember hurricanes
i knew that sounds like a liquidator
that came to take the shed back
i think people sounds like the drunk
neighbor who drove his car through it
and people are gonna know how old i am
because hurricane bob
i don't remember it was bad i don't
remember hurricane bomb
hit a hit and he's [ __ ] 90. yeah i'm
44. he's a meteorologist too
helpful hit the northeast pretty hard
huh okay
uh was the jungle gym one of those nice
wooden ones or was it metal
wooden and they assembled it for us and
i remember when they assembled it
because me and this other little girl
was like five or six we put on our
bikinis to watch these guys construct it
and we like threw popcorn at them like
it's not the pedophile's fault every
time
we were begging for it i can't she's out
there with like a lot for the popsicle
i got mirrors in my bedroom um hold on i
just want to stop
yeah that's a huge thing that's very the
wooden
swing set dude very expensive
guys putting it together not your dad
with [ __ ] two yinglings in them
[ __ ]
screaming two drunk uncles or something
yeah he was working
that's great i do we i wanted one so bad
as a kid my kid on my block at the top
of the hill got one and i remember like
begging my dad and he was finally worn
down after like a [ __ ] year
i said we'll go we used to drive by it
and we pull in and he puts like i don't
know let's say it was like 700 bucks or
something
they're expensive yeah he put like a 300
deposit cash down on it
and then he's like like the two weeks
later i'm like yeah they're supposed to
come
on like the following tuesday to put it
in there no show somebody that's calling
them or not answer here they just
[ __ ] went out of business
they too it was like the last thing they
took is 300 bucks and he
never how garbage he is so [ __ ] he still
feels that 300.
every time for years after we drive by
those [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] 3 4
people
was there any summer camp any sleep away
camp yes
i went to a lot of different ones sleep
away yeah
this kid she's rich kids kid's class i
got a lot of scholarships though i went
to the boston ballet
ballet camp that was a three-week
program in boston that was expensive
sleep away i did acting camp
that was like oh like a week of it you
you stayed at a camp and then it was
like you would just go during the day
okay and then when i was in high school
i went to the university of texas
for two summers but this isn't camp at
this point right this is like i i was
like um
it depends what you went there for it
was a speech and debate if it was
football
it was like your skill building and
stuff like that yeah but like you know
how it was like a football camp like it
like if you were really into something
you go like that's classy a university
and get even better at it
i'm saying if you went there just
because football camp was in session
that would be trashy
yeah no no i was like um you would like
you would get your speech and debate
pieces together in the summertime to
compete
and debate to compete i was the captain
ranked fifth in the country when i was a
senior
what'd you get in your sats 1290 1390
1390s
sorry ari was thirteen fifty twelve
fifty twelve fifty
maybe it was twelve ninety either way
pretty good twelve ninety or thirteen
ninety i'm not
i actually think of mikko didn't amiko
have like a [ __ ] thirteen seven
fourteen hundreds
it was high though that's why i got into
marymount i got the presidential
scholarship it was like a 75
scholarship damn wow yeah i would get
smart i'm just lazy
[Laughter]
the wicket just took that wicked
wow okay interesting hmm
kevin turn the floor over to you i don't
know where i'm [ __ ] i can't she's
like wallpaper i can't take a read on
her
um let's let's move into like you know
uh
have you ever dated a guy who sold weed
no
i thought that was a dead giveaway
you're sure i thought
was [ __ ] sleeping with some dude who
sold qps or something
sold coke no no drug dealer of any kind
no
so you have no current connections
[Laughter]
fair enough have you ever taken a
full-size pillow
no neck pillow once in a while but
rarely
how do you travel i'm light i i i'm very
compact i can fall asleep anywhere in
like little spaces i'll i'll roll like a
it's pretty good but like like um no i'm
not like for have to be first class all
the time
first class live first question no no
but once in a while it's nice to treat
yourself
wow have you ever flown first class yeah
my cousin bought me and take it one time
it was a company card or something let
me ask you this
if your family's going on vacation uh
growing up yeah would you guys know
first class okay absolutely not
do you ever see me those families oh my
god yeah they're [ __ ] mcallisters
that's why i [ __ ] that kid
my parents [ __ ] flying first class to
france good thing he got lost
the [ __ ] did he do anyway mr mcallister
was [ __ ] oh he was
qp's i tell you huh definitely banging
his secretary
okay wow i think as of now she's like
bulletproof glass have you ever flown
private
no hmm interesting you're on a cruise
yes hate them why why are we on the
cruise why'd you go just
my parents took me and my sister because
my brother was in
france and we were it was like the
school vacation it's like an april
vacation you took the boat to france
no my brother was in france so we went
on we were doing something
i was like yeah your brothers and
friends will take you on a cruise what
was he doing in france
school trip i went on the same one when
i was a junior school trip to france we
went to the [ __ ] you had to be good
to the
holy sh i want to know what's going on
in the [ __ ] live chat right now there
better be [ __ ] head spinning
this went to is unbelievable i went to
say i went to a catholic private school
damn yeah were you were you guys
religious growing up
yes until we got a new month senior and
he had this
whole like what are they called the
homily of the sermon after the gospel
one time and it was just very anti-gay
and my parents were just very close with
the lesbian couple as i mentioned before
sure so they were like we're over this
but i went when i was younger
very every sunday let me tell you
something having a lesbian couple in the
neighborhood
they keep the [ __ ] place tight
absolutely property values
soar and they're always a bit they don't
have their own kids they were around for
babysitting they had a dog named wicket
my mom would chain smoke with them in
their living room
trashy that is trashy there we go with
me in the room
smoking indoors i now have asthma your
mom smoked
oh yeah newports oh maureen
here we go now it's starting there we go
now
the [ __ ] okay that's why everybody
loves this show eventually yeah
[Music]
your mom's smoking a pack of ports in
the [ __ ] den
did you ever go and buy them for she
used to do sit-ups in the backyard in a
sports bra
[ __ ] smoking like oh she in the yard
every time like that's like [ __ ] yeah
every time she wants to drop the dog
that's like what they did at the rock
she used to call it her ian's diet
caffeine and nicotine she would just
drink coffee smoke bots for like two
we need to get her in here this brawl is
wacky she's [ __ ] awesome
and she was a teacher growing up yes
special ed
wow special ed the cat jesus christ
couple of flaws here and there but
still pretty clean have you ever stolen
makeup from the store
yeah yeah when was it like a habit
or recently not recently but not that
long
year two two years ago why do you just
do that
the rush that's crazy you're not that
guy but a lot of our friends will steal
candy bars from 7-eleven
i wouldn't want to get caught as a fat
guy stealing candy
i'm talking about like 200 skincare
products like
that's trashy just christ
i wasn't always i wasn't always rich you
could get in the vault sephora
sephora is no joke man i've always had
rich taste yeah i got that about you
wow so you stole that a necessity yeah
that's see that's a little less garbage
of doing it for the rush yeah hopefully
they don't like but the russians
this is this is working technically
therapy sephora cops are going to come
looking for you yeah yeah we're looking
for feet
rouge team go rouge team go
oh so fun okay i got one all right
do you cut or bite your nails
i get manicures i usually do this i
don't know
rock driver i used to bite my cuticles
though i used to bite my cuticles there
were times in my life when i was like
nervous and like if i was ever
going through some [ __ ] my thumbnails
would look really really bad but i'm
better now
did you suck your thumb growing up
probably but not like not like got to a
point where not to like high school
no i knew someone who sucked it until
high school get those [ __ ] big buck
teeth
we used to have a kid bucko shout out
the buck going you might listen you've
liked a couple of posts
bucko had a big set of chompers on them
what about twirling your hair anything
like that no no i don't have that many
that many gross
habits okay anything in your apartment
right now that says live laugh love
no no tchotchkes like that no but
i have a magnet that says when i die the
dog gets everything
that's cute i'll give you that itchy
it's not it's kitschy what's the scented
candle situation
over there oh i'm more of like a i burn
um palo alto wood
please know what i'm talking about that
like sounds you think those bozos are
gonna know what do you think
[Laughter]
there's three dudes in there and two
sleeves you do the math they're not
[ __ ] light and scented candles or
know what
beechwood is i know our our guy joe the
irish barely made it to new york and you
will
i don't think he's [ __ ] burning sage
any yoga studio
that's the scent typically not you
you're good
yeah i mean when you have to pee and you
walk into a yoga studio by accident
when you fake like you're going to join
uh how much are memberships here where's
the bathroom can i grab a cone what's it
build
i'd like to talk to that girl with a
nice ass
yes i do i'm a progressive
okay so you don't bite your nails don't
do anything like that
hmm growing up would your gut would you
guys eat a tv dinner
no my brother once in a while would do
the hungry man dinners
but my mom hated it we all gave him [ __ ]
for it how many nights a week would you
guys eat at a table together as a family
like five like four to five growing up a
lot wow my mom cooked a lot
tv on it all or no like no that's not
high
did you ever eat in the living room on
the coffee table no that wasn't our
thing we were we were really good and
until we got older and we're really busy
with activities and like deal
meals sure sure we were really good
about eating together would your parents
have a cocktail or wine with dinner
okay that would have been classy just
for the record yeah yeah
one cocktail is really classy now that
weren't you they were big drinkers they
only drank with their friends
they did this thing called the tree
toasting where every christmas they
would pick a different house in the
neighborhood and they would go
toast their tree how cute right and they
would get drunk and sing carols
throughout the neighborhood oh come
on that's pretty [ __ ] i'm i'm excited
for christmas this year too i just want
to [ __ ] i'm doing it i want to go on a
record i'm down at the fee
house yeah and they would let me babysit
all the kids
babysitter molest jesus dump it
i was like like 14 like a bunch of
six-year-old jesus
i was gonna ask you that who babysat you
growing up that's a big sign of trash
um we had babysitters there was marnie
who taught me how to swim
in her pool which was across the street
so they were legit babysitter not like a
cousin that was
hanging around no no there was always
like young like
cute girls that my parents hired buried
nice
i used to love that high school can i
just digress for a second is what that's
what the show is
hooking up with when you were hooking up
with a girl that babysat for rich people
and you go over there and hook up with
her and [ __ ] go into the pantry
yeah dude i had one [ __ ] suburban
fantasy i tell you cool
one of the girls brought her boyfriend
over and ended up he threw
me down the stick i forget wait what
wait what yeah like oh you were being
babysitter we were being babysitted i
was the high school
you came over to my house right yeah i
would come over to your house and i was
like send you to bed real quick
i was like sick benadryl [ __ ] yeah
sticking it in my ice cream sandwich and
[ __ ] hey eat up
so i gave the bald kid a little michael
so we had a little private time
we were bad kids we were real bad kids
and something happened
we were like [ __ ] mouthy too you know
what i mean because we thought we were
tough i was a six-year-old who thought
he was tough
that's trash when you're a six-year-old
you think you're tough i was like i was
like yeah go [ __ ] yourself or something
and he [ __ ] muffed my face down the
stairs
i didn't know what the [ __ ] happened i
ran over got my neighbor shout out to
[ __ ] i don't want to say his name
i got big b came over and he was like
what's going on over here
as a six-year-old dude who babysat you
really defines your detraction
also my buddy hit my buddy had a
babysitter we would like be over his
house and
this [ __ ] slob from the northeast
would come she was like looking back
like a troll
and she would show us porn looking back
she'd be like yeah yeah you can watch
porn on cinemax or whatever
like like we wanted to read a book yeah
but i was also like 14 or something it
was like before the internet
yeah i was thinking about where the
sidewalk ends but all right let's do a
little skin of max
star wars we had this woman from the
neighborhood that used to babysit us god
love her
uh she was she was a little slow she was
mentally challenged and just
perfect dude me and my brother were
[ __ ] two of the biggest pieces of
[ __ ] to this woman
ever yeah we'd [ __ ] we'd pretend to
go to bed all right she'd be downstairs
watching her program
she used to eat these butter pretzels i
don't know she would show up with her
own snacks
that's bad that's really to thank them
if you're not cause if you're not like
on it
if you're like bringing celery because
you're like hey i'm watching my cards
but if you're bringing your own buttery
treats
now they were rolling the dice by
[ __ ] leaving us and we would sneak
down
after we knew she thought we had fallen
asleep and we'd sneak up behind her and
just [ __ ] yank the chair out from
behind her
and let her flip back she would freak
the [ __ ] out
it
was
we would throw my dog we had a beagle a
mean [ __ ] beagle and we would throw
he loved cheese so we would throw cheese
on the babysitter while she was on the
couch
we'd get like 50 craft singles so she
couldn't dodge him that's just hilarious
and the dog would [ __ ] go crazy would
he bite her
oh yeah not like not like intentionally
but like he's trying to get
the sheep he's all hyped up he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's the super fun
yelling at me you're [ __ ] sick and
the dog on the baby she had all of her
marbles
she could have [ __ ] you know what was
the boyfriend doing i don't know where
he was i'm so tough now huh
yeah sicko come back i'll throw cheese
at you [ __ ] i can't remember did you
say you had a dog growing up yes our
first dog was half small
her name was kelly she looked like a
white wolf that's very nice i like that
that's
very classy however i the question would
you allow the dog to lick the plates
after you guys were done dinner
before it went into the dishwasher my
dad would yeah trash
yeah my dad also let her lick his feet
for hours oh
every like all the time just like he was
just weird
it would like like he would switch feets
oh my toes are cringing mirrors in the
bedroom huh she would get back in there
mr freehand's bit of a freak that's
trashy see we're always gonna find it
all right you know what i mean joey okay
we're always gonna find it all right
um growing up did your family have bacon
bits
once in a while but that wasn't our
thing yeah hmm have you or any member of
your family ever had turkey
a full turkey on any other day but
thanksgiving
no no it's very clever would you guys do
thanksgiving at the house
uh thanksgiving was typically at my
karen's house growing up
but sounds nice we did christmas uh
christmas day or christmas eve uh we
would do
both but christmas eve would have a
smaller party
smaller amount of people there it'd be
like my uncle bob and his wife and we
get chinese food
and then the next day we would have
christmas we'd have everybody come over
the chinese thing yeah that's a thing
i've always done that still do it now we
open all our presents on christmas eve
and do chinese food oh yeah i do
i do i do as well now since we got older
and he thinks it's the trashiest
it's garbage you open presents christmas
day you can open one christmas night if
it's a pair of pajamas
or like or if you're [ __ ] seven if
you're an adult you don't need to wait
till christmas morning you [ __ ]
have to wait for santa and he doesn't
give a [ __ ] you're allowed to open your
pj's and put your foot
up all right so i don't get new pajamas
on christmas eve and in the pictures
there's yeah enough fabric in the north
pole opening presents on christmas eve
unless it's
one after midnight mass is trash for
us chinese food ain't helping either
i'll tell you that for our family my
brother's the only one with kids right
now and he spends christmas day with his
wife sure so you do
that's what's the same thing happened
with us as you get older they have kids
and the kid they're going to go
somewhere else
that's a rip-off by the way i would make
them go back and forth one year to one
year make them
absolutely no i mean you should make
them buy you a new shirt too by the way
i like i enjoy my knees and nephew for
like two hours at a time
i don't really need both a lot mm-hmm
it's a lot it's a lot they physically
hurt me
hmm huh interesting
dude i'm we're like a nine she's batting
like a 90 [ __ ] percent
class here well it was a couple
blemishes but i got one
what was the local campaign signage at
the house
always democrat but there was local
campaign signs in the front yard
oh yeah i'm like did we have one we we
wouldn't get that anyway but people in
our neighborhood would
okay yeah long as you didn't have them
out there if you have like
joe reynolds for judge you're [ __ ] no
unless you're related to joe reynolds
you shouldn't be doing that no
no county commissioner um did you guys
ever have a chia pet growing up
no hmm how do you feel about imitation
crab meat
no yeah what it's good what i don't know
private school kids don't eat imitation
crab meat that's for you and the rest of
the doc workers
they do at public school yeah that's
their special once that's a special on
fridays
we got ceviche the other day and it had
fake crab meat shut up pet store yeah
[Laughter]
it was at some place in uh near west
point it was pretty good
okay do did you ever smoke cigs or do
you currently smoke steaks uh i
would smoke them once in a while at like
stand-up shows like okay
just yeah yeah i would host a lot so
like not that i don't love my fellow
comedians comedy and want to
see their art it's a time killer social
thing i should go out and smoke but
since quarantine have not
smoked a cigarette wow so i feel like i
was never really addicted
okay hmm i'm a raging alcoholic and i
have a tattoo that says don't serve me
on
my wrist yeah that's pretty who did the
tattoo um bartender guy name yeah
this guy named jeremy i don't know okay
it's always weird like sometimes it's
like ah [ __ ] like we had julio julia
was like yeah pete davidson
like that shit's wild yeah pete davidson
did mine
ever vacation at a lake no good that can
be classy though
no yeah it can be under no circumstances
we had a lake house growing up and it
was [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] garbage we had a boat we
had wait it was like it was ricky bob it
was like new money type [ __ ] for sure
no money but there's dope lake house yes
there is dope [ __ ]
like cuomo like in italy with [ __ ]
george clooney woah you idiot
like like cuomo not cuomo he's the
governor
yeah yeah it's lake como he's also got
that hot brother and i've been there you
guys both because i'm clean
like you swim in
[Laughter]
yeah okay what about a toe ring uh
when i was in junior high yeah i put sun
in my hair when i was in june
my mom kept saying that she looks like a
[ __ ] puerto rican next to us we're
all irish dark hair look at this yeah
that's such an irish thing to sit like
porch i was either portuguese or puerto
rican she didn't care
yeah it's very like you look puerto
rican just cause like blue like trashy
people
just identify groups of people by their
nationality you know what i mean
like i'm from a huge irish catholic
trash family from philadelphia and
my wife is jewish they'll be like i've
never seen a jew broad like you and i'm
like ah all right
i'm like the guy who brought one into
you know they're like ah
a jewish girl play sports you never hear
that i'm like all right let's tone it
down
you [ __ ] jerk off my grandfather
she's like what the [ __ ]
my grandfather came to visit me we took
a cab and he's not even sitting down yet
he's like are you from calcutta
watching the discovery championship rest
in peace ginkgo
ah hmm have you ever i got one have you
ever smoked pot out of a soda can
yep yeah how long ago no
like teenager like early teen yeah yeah
no i've made like a bong out of like a
water bottle like not that long ago
gravity bombs do we gotta do sometimes
okay i got one do you drink coffee yeah
are you more of a duncan or starbucks
well you know the answer that's gonna be
i grew up on duncan i grew up on duncan
duncan even the way you're [ __ ]
stonking yeah
i grew up on duncan but i love starbucks
too i'm a caffeine fiend so for me it's
like whatever
okay but if i had a choice it depends on
the time of day though you know
if i need to get up or like have
diarrhea i'm drinking starbucks yeah you
gotta go you gotta go big
for sure but if it's an afternoon coffee
i'll go dunkin wait diarrhea
caffeine helps that absolutely what does
you ever heard of like
coffee makes you [ __ ] yeah yeah if you
have diarrhea why would you want to ship
more
because you have a date yeah you got to
get it out speed up the process you know
what i mean it's pretty cool nothing
little booster
i love [ __ ] is that classy my
family's
my family's so trashy that they found
that they started drinking starbucks and
they made they they think it's a thing
to make fun of me like right why don't
you tell them where you get your coffee
at kevin
you're [ __ ] queer new yorker you know
what i mean i'm like
uh starbucks there's about 70 000 of
them in that country it's
frappuccino kevin over here my dad hates
it my dad hates it so much
currently or growing up did your toilets
contain or contain now the product known
as blue magic
[Laughter]
growing up yeah my dad makes you feel
like you're in a ball game or something
is that it's blue magic with like the
the thing they drop in and it depends it
all it turns it like [ __ ] windex ends
up killing the dog
yeah that couldn't have been good for
pets yeah oh what no it's terrain
now mine looks like brown magic um
anyone in your family ever have just a
hot tub
no pool just a hot tub no okay
do you currently have a p.o box no
pretty good pretty clean have you ever
left a bad yelp review
no what brand of toothpaste do you
currently use crest
middle of the road not bad not bad sense
of dine is the number one answer
nine out of ten tennis recommend it just
use promo code garbage everybody when
you're checking out at sensodyne
questions are so good what was your what
was the vehicle situation
all right so growing up my mom had a
toyota sienna
or a toyota previa she would be she
treated that's the van right yes
sienna's the van i've never heard of a
princess
it was a van before the sienna i think
similar style though but it was because
my mom
um worked but it would also like do
carpool
sure so we would pick up a few other
kids in the neighborhood and drive
because a few kids in our neighborhood
went to prisons like the [ __ ]
cleavers private pretty good man the
whole the whole ballet
yeah it's pretty classy and i played
soccer and softball and tennis growing
up until i quit all of them to focus on
ballet
jesus that's pretty classy but my mom
took a stick at it my dad had a company
car though my dad had a company car that
the company like gave him and here look
at me company cars were
big in the 90s yeah great and then my
mom had that van
and then she would come pick us up from
school and slide that door open and she
would always have tons of candy
so kids would jump in the van grab candy
be like hey mrs finn you're so cool get
it out and then get out
then when i started doing speech and
debate my mom started letting people
smoke cigarettes in her van
in high school but wouldn't let me she
smoked
that's [ __ ] dude any time the mom let
you smoke [ __ ] cigs in the car
you should have kept that to yourself
jesus christ that's practical
kids smoke i you know you seem pretty
your mom plays it [ __ ]
fast her philosophy was she's like
they're gonna [ __ ] smoke anyway at
least i can work that's a trashy
vegetarian
right there do you do it in front of me
so i know you're not but yeah whatever
yeah
we had that mom she was a divorced mom
it was the first time we got drunk
was with her and her boyfriend they went
out on a friday night
picked us up a couple cases of beer i
think they had a couple of [ __ ] eight
balls on them too
that guy was up for a real that guy
could talk he wanted to start a business
too it was weird
i think we should start business
together but that was her thing i'd
rather have you do it here than someone
else which is great
and it's good life experience so you
don't go to college and act like a
[ __ ] idiot yeah like having your
first beer
right but but my mom was also like a
little naive about things like i had
people over once and like
she brought us down like i think there
was probably like eight kids there and
she brought us down a six-pack of bud
light yeah
she's like here you go guys but we're
like we're pulling out handles of vodka
from under the couch oh
sure sure yeah uh underage drinking oh
the best time of my life
man there was nothing better than
drinking like [ __ ] 12 mgds and then
smoking
marlboro milds out front of my buddy
justin's house
we used to drink uh busch light we call
them blue yummies so i dated this one
guy
these are called blue yummies and i get
wasted off like four
[Music]
we had money growing up like even kids
like because like we were like upper
middle class whatever and so like the
kids had money too coming up
yeah what yeah it depended depending on
the year we we bounced back and forth
that's how much copper pipe was going
we got number copper number one copper
the scrap yards
um so like all the kids had cat like or
at least hey
you get like we never drank shitty beer
we never drank like
natty or [ __ ] bush or any of that
[ __ ] yeah we all
like we would drink miller like coors
light whatever like at least like 20
they were like 20
20 bucks for a 30 pack but we got our
hands on uh lebat blues
nice we found out about those once one
winter yeah called them big and tasty
do about 10 of them you'd be [ __ ]
driving home i mean not driving home
right yeah i used to always drive drunk
i would put my head out the window i
mean i wasn't like full drunk
mark this down so we can dump it
stealing from sephora driving drunk
that's what i cried when i asked you
about cars i was asking what was your
car what was your car in high school
so my parents bought me a 1990 toyota
corolla it was probably like three grand
mm-hmm and just rent yeah just that was
it what color was it white i named her
blanche i put
zebra like [ __ ] like stuff on the seats
right that's what i was gonna ask you
did you have any aftermarket
auditions trashy did my dad put a stereo
system in that car with a little
subwoofer
any fake rims on it no spoiler no
okay cd changer no that was my my best
friend
um gabby growing up had a ultima tinted
wig
what was the [ __ ] if you could get
your hands on an altar ultimate or a
maximum
oh man ultimate but like i went to
school with kids who even had like um
like beam or range rovers like yeah they
like they would come to school like
after their 16th birthday i was like oh
that's what you're working with
sure i've been doing this i remember
this kid pulled up in like a [ __ ] 55
000 silver corvette with like the
convertible oh my god
and that was a lot dude i was sitting in
my [ __ ] 1995
chevy lumina with the pain still driving
paint chipping off of that
front if you want to see it yeah man i
just remember being like
[ __ ] yeah gabby was [ __ ] loaded her
parents were travel agents she was
oh she had the tiffany's this is a
question you guys should ask
with girls tiffany's charm bracelets did
you have the tiffany's bracelet because
to me
some people have oh that's classy but
it's not that's [ __ ] gaudy and goofy
yeah if you're wearing it to school it's
good if you're going to a you know
if you're where you know it depends
where you're wearing it it's too basic
it's too obvious but i remember as a
high school kid trying to buy my
girlfriend one right and rolling into
the tiffany's up here like when we came
up for christmas
yeah i was escorted out of the building
yeah i'd rather
the mcdonald's is down the street you
guys just got a can opener or something
i could buy it
how do you feel about coleslaw i love it
i just had some excellent coleslaw today
kevin what's your verdict on that try
[ __ ] keep don't even bring it out on
my plate
luke's lobster and uh dumbo i've had two
of their lobster rolls
they're lobster rolls they're great top
not maybe the best i had to see mores
the night before i've had three lobster
rolls in the past
40 years that's pretty [ __ ] close and
[ __ ]
in lunch oh yeah i just got back from um
the uh one hotel in dumbo in brooklyn i
stayed there for a couple days because i
had a rooftop pool
i needed a pool very nice but i don't
think that's classy
can i explain it's trashy that you're
spending the money to do that that's
trashy
oh you stayed at a hotel in the city no
that's nice uh a staycation
i enjoy a staycation i have i've done it
before however if i had my druthers and
if i was a little bit of a better
planner i would prefer
to have my own house obviously like a
pool that i don't have to deal with
these other
they are trashy like i'm a cute hotel
guest and i'm minding my own business
but there's
very opinionated garbage garbage that
comes through this [ __ ] hotel i'm
like how much did you save up for this
night
all year you [ __ ] present
right down the [ __ ] street i'm here
oh my god this woman had like her kids
like naked in the pool and i'm just like
what if i just [ __ ] put my head on
this i don't know
i i it's some people just don't know how
to [ __ ] ask
that's very true and i'm typically one
of those guys i try to
i always feel i was a couple weeks ago i
went to the [ __ ] yacht club and we
were like swimming
and uh i knew i i knew they knew i was a
guest
you know what i mean like oh yeah it was
like i knew but like i act accordingly i
don't make it a [ __ ] scene but like
also
the people i was with had like [ __ ] they
like filled up coolers of [ __ ]
twisted tee and [ __ ] i'm like
why don't we just [ __ ] order and
we'll [ __ ] you know we'll settle it
up somehow like
i [ __ ] roll it in like we're going to
an eagles game yeah we're going to a
[ __ ] yacht club what are we doing
half cash half card that's garbage can
you can you split the chicken fingers
between three different cards
ooh my brother has a boat does that go
towards my score that's very nine to
vote
like not a crazy one just like a regular
one he takes out with the family you can
like sit on it
up there up in cape cod yeah cape
that's where my parents live now and
then my dad works as a bartender on the
ferry that goes in between cape cod and
nantucket
talk about a nice retirement gig loves
it loves it
that's god do you guys like cape cod
i've never been
chips well to us that's [ __ ] that all
we just know that is rich [ __ ] yeah
like rich people because you only hear
it immediate movies and shows
vineyards hamptons that's all the same
because we we went further south cod's i
think a little more down to earth than
the hampton kenny bunkport
maine i went to school with kenny
bunkport
but yeah so but but but they're we're
not talking like old money like we're
talking like my parents both work there
sure sure i'm in the same boat but like
yeah yeah but like it's also
i'm it's very similar like your mom is
[ __ ] trash regardless of how much
money she makes
so it's like she's still going to be
[ __ ] you know smoking sick because
she's
in the lobby of the hotel but my dad
grew up way trashier than she did
my dad grew up in dorchester and like
what yesterday triple decker like
life of crime kicked out a minute three
deca men at best knocking open bread
trucks
we're upset we're obsessed with all
things boston
sometimes we just call each other and
we'll just speak like we're from southie
for like
so fun but we only can say like seven
words each so the conversation just
keeps going in a circle all right let's
get back on track here
that's right all right um we're coming
up let's uh let's do some of the basic
staples that we do
you know at the end i like it all righty
i'd like to know a couple of things now
sure go for it buddy uh do you keep
bread in the freezer
no no you could if you're garbage i
don't eat a lot of bread you're in a lot
of bread if you have bread
do you after you take bread out of the
con out of the package
do you twist tie it back up do you tie
it in a knot or do you fold it
under like a [ __ ] animal i i usually
twist tight because i lose the plastic
thing
you'll actually twist high though not
that i'll nod it yeah that's tough
though
let's have get it open again yeah that's
just so much head it's just trying to
work
i know my own strength and i try to
leave it you got a little little loose
yeah you still get a finger in there the
garbage is folding it underneath and
you do it twist and flip you don't just
trash twist
growing up oh i am pure trash growing up
did you have milk with dinner
yes nice there we go that is
like anything like pasta lasagna pork
chops
mac and cheese pork chops and milk how
about spaghetti like spaghetti and milk
daddy my dad would make spaghetti
do you still do it no i'll drink milk
with cookies though give me a bag of
tapes say good night
second only to the milano double stubble
double double
dark chocolate double dark chocolate
horse okay i like the pepperidge farms a
little bouquet that they put
who doesn't call the classics collection
i love it because then you get the chest
mess you got the brussels
ah the cheddar the brussels i don't know
what's in there you know what's
nice too it's it's definitely a lower
class
but the blue tin with like of course
they come in like the little
cupcakes yeah the shortbread cookies
some of them have sugar sprinkles on
them
yeah there's like a pretzel-shaped one a
square one
if no one's looking i'll crush one of
those oh pirouette down the hatch
seal and then after that you got to put
your sewing stuff in there and put it in
the drawer that's what everything
that's like a stereotypical thing all
right
all right um currently
do you have any ketchup packets in your
apartment no do you have a drawer that
has
old no she i've seen on instagram she's
it's her apartment's kind of sterile
it's very not sterile but it's very
together
it's definitely not foley's apartment
you got a swiffer yeah
a wet jet i got a dust buster and then i
have a swiffer weft jet and a broom i
have a dog
no but i should get a dice i should i
should invest i have a nice classy
individual
yeah you should get it what's the ac
situation i only have a window unit one
window unit
bedroom or living room bedroom standard
network i live
i don't have roommates i live alone in a
one-bedroom apartment
in manhattan in manhattan so you were in
brooklyn okay
i was until i got money a little bit of
cage
and the attitude to go with him yeah
right she's been rich her whole life
she's finally just catching up to the
bankroll you know what i mean yeah
do you own any jewelry that contains
turquoise no
very nice wait this might be turquoise
and that is garbage that is fresh there
we go
from the garbage my sister got me this
that's my favorite necklace
from mephanies shut up okay
i'm making it i'm trying not to just
zoom in
i don't know if it's turquoise also why
are they close to my face
i believe it is my wrinkles dylan on the
creep cam
[Laughter]
my sister got me that turquoise me i i
want nice jewelry i'm gonna go get some
right after this just so i can come back
on this podcast and be classier
nice silver is nice okay that's what you
guys like on it
silver diamonds is nice i want to get a
gold chain though i'll get you one
yeah yeah steal it sephora no i'll buy
it for you thank you there you go
you're welcome um has anyone ever named
a star after you
no no no one's ever loved me
no one's ever loved me with star law
yeah nobody's ever loved me enough to
like
write an email have you in recent memory
ever scratch your name in the sidewalk
no have you ever wrote wash me on the on
a dirty car windshield what is she in
the [ __ ] little rascals
no the [ __ ] is wrong with you i'm ruling
things out she's got a housing cape god
her brother's got a boat
she's doing staycations at like
five-star hotels
she carves her name in wet cement i
carved mine and my exes initialed into
um the eiffel tower when i was in paris
oh damn that's funny my high school
boyfriend
i loved him huh he's married with kids
i hope he listens shout out to dave
puppy listens
and wants me back that's real classy the
eiffel
the eiffel tower kevin i know you're
riding the [ __ ]
the the wicked sailor at [ __ ]
wildwood
i haven't done much international travel
in a long time though i have to get on
that
that's still pretty good i've been in
the eiffel tower it's more than i've
been yeah
i've always never left the country it
was in delaware once yeah never left the
country
well i live near chinatown you can take
a whiff
get the vibe not
missing much all right yeah you want big
ones
yeah release the butter put the butter
in the fridge leave it on the counter
in the fridge class it's irish catholic
okay and ketchup you open a bottle of
ketchup where do you put it
fridge but i don't even really use
ketchup okay what about maple syrup
i love maple syrup i don't have any i
want to get some okay fridge
fridge keep it in the fridge you like it
like luke warm like what
i think the good syrup the good stuff
you got to keep in the fridge no you
don't that's the
it's in the tree and it's natural you
leave it in the cabbage
i like the mentality of like the warm
dessert and the butter i see where
you're going
yes what we do is what my mom will do is
she'll take
half syrup inject it right india half
butter and she'll put it in the
microwave for a couple of seconds
and then mix it together put that over a
[ __ ] only trash
over an egg doing that for frozen
[ __ ] water you guys used to put i
used to put a little bit of butter in
every one of the
[ __ ] love eggs dude you know how
trash i was i would just [ __ ] i would
[ __ ] make an eggo and just eat it
like after school just like it was like
a piece of [ __ ]
i guess just like it was a cracker i
would just sit there and eat eggos i got
into microwaving them during the
quarantine
and putting ham and cheese and a little
bit of syrup in there jesus christ
yeah like a little trashy monte cristo
[ __ ] not too
shabby dude it's a croc
[ __ ] one day we didn't have any
cheese so i used a cheese stick i used
i used a piece of ham and put a cheese
stick in there not bad
shout out to polio and make a fine
product shout out to peloton i'm gonna
drop the top of your house
i'm gonna buy you a pelican
dude you never cease to amaze me
honestly that's crazy
crazy good okay okay
all right karen see him yeah
what's the ruling i don't know dylan do
we have anything in the chat that sticks
out as far as a
big question let's see one second
nothing lewd please family
i gotta i'm going she's class
did you wear uggs no oh that's even
pretty even still
nah a lot of i never had hugs never
owned those crocs what was your phone as
a kid
nokia that stan everybody had the nokia
3100 everybody had that was standard do
you ever have a sidekick
the phone no call me when you want call
me on my sidekick son
i had one i thought i made like a little
fat kid i was like
my last boyfriend was kind of a beta wow
i had a slide kick i had the one that
slid up
all because lil wayne mentioned it in a
song so i went and bought one did you
ever want to slip and slide yes
uh yeah but like one summer
like randomly okay you need to make your
own no no no
i mean i gotta you know we're we're
we're [ __ ] grasping at straws here to
find something to make her trash
this broad is class i think off the
bottom i have i'm classy with glimmers
of trash though
i don't honestly i don't see any
glimmers of trash
oh wow i mean in your mom that bro is a
little rough around the edges
maureen yeah we get her in here she'd be
[ __ ] flipping the table
all shocked up with the [ __ ] wet fact
she got electrocuted
holy [ __ ]
wow saying it right now i think you
might take the cake too i don't think
we've had anybody come in here
and [ __ ] bat away our questions
left and right like wow you might be the
classiest person
i know i mean i guess the bar is pretty
low the bar's low and you came in
and i mean it's we can't even get close
to that anymore yeah what do you boys
think back there yeah what do you guys
think class dylan
dylan doesn't think i'm classy i i i
think it's i think it's
class come from trash so take that
from trash [ __ ] ballerina the shed
that looked like the house
house in cape cod a boat
i think i think she's class yeah class
she's class following through
all class wow 98 she's clean yeah
100 the other 2 is my hpv
hey which 95 of people are gonna have in
five years anyway so she's ahead of the
curve
she's a trendsetter wow i'm [ __ ]
shocked i'm just as surprised as you
guys i'm baffled
pretty good man pretty good bulletproof
disc bra anything out there you want the
folks to know anything you got coming up
any
where they can see you you know i've
been uh i'm host i don't know when this
is coming out
it'll be out monday thursday i've been
hosting a lot of shows at the stand and
they're doing shows thursdays fridays
and saturdays outdoor seating social
distancing get on their email list
um and yeah follow me on instagram um go
chip chipperson
awesome very nice kippy what do you got
the folks out there now hit him a little
business
yeah let's get so let's get some some
some things moving here
obviously uh itunes make sure you rate
review subscribe there
full video available on youtube you can
subscribe there also guys sign up for
gas digital if you want to help
uh me and foley you can sign up at gas
digital use promo code a-y-g
yes and you'll get a whole bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] you get access to all the
shows on the network
uh you get our episodes beforehand you
got the hd video
yeah you get a whole bunch of [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] worth it so
uh sign up you get a discount if you use
code ayg and we get to wet our beaks
which
we're doing this for so [ __ ] do it
yes sir we thank everybody out there
everybody working the first second third
shift
out there listening to are you garbage
we love you we have a couple of people
hit us up say they've been working the
second shift and then it's get we're
getting them through
we love you guys uh at agefolio on ice
on twitter foleygrams on instagram
and uh we'll see you next week we love
yous peace peace
oh man thank you so much